welcome to the
recruitment mentors podcast my name is
hisham
azuz today i'm delighted to be joined by
gabby trotter
who joined the recruitment industry when
she was just 19 years old
and for the last five years has worked
at search ability
recruiting the best testing talent in
yorkshire
and the north west and for the last two
and a half years has also been
responsible for
a small team as well as billing gabby
thank you for uh
joining me on the podcast thank you very
much for having me i'm looking forward
to it
so where i want to start this podcast
moving forward
is in your opinion what characteristics
and traits do you think
make up a highly successful recruitment
consultant
good question and i'm glad that you
asked me this in advance because i had
to have you know a serious think about
this because
it's so hard to boil it down to you know
one or two particular traits and i think
obviously it varies massively depending
on what sector you operate in and
what your role is whether you're a
manager or you're just looking after
yourself
and i kind of thought you know for me
what i look for when i recruit for my
team
one of the the biggest things i look for
is someone who
is organized and someone who has got the
ability to
have control of the day rather than let
the day run away with them
i think a lot of this job is about being
kind of in the right place at the right
time
so organization is so important in terms
of what you're doing during the day and
just making sure that you don't miss
opportunities uh
if someone says to me call me in a
month's time you know you best believe
in a month's time
exactly at 9am i am calling them i've
set the reminder there's no way that i'm
going to forget about that because
that's a
golden nugget of opportunity so
organization
and i think integrity is huge as well
i know that might be a bit controversial
because i'm sure there's some recruiters
out there that are doing very well and
maybe have questionable
um you know
for me and especially if you work in a
niche sector like i work in
you know your reputation will massively
precede you so
integrity is key treating people like
you would want to be treated if
the shoe is on the other foot that's my
kind of two key things i look for
everything else i think could be teached
i love that and i think let's
i think the goal here is to make sure
the integrity isn't controversial
because i i think that's what you know i
mean in the recruitment industry i think
it should definitely not be
controversial
but i have to ask you before we dig into
your
your journey how do you so how do you
look for
organization in an interview of interest
besides
i don't know just turn up on time doing
all those things like how
how do you look for that in someone i
think
you have to ask the right questions
so if someone has been in a retail or a
sales role before
asking them how they would manage their
day what targets they had to work to
during the day and how they made sure
they hit those
um if someone's fresh out of you name
that's great because i feel you can
really gauge
um someone's level of organization by
just talking to them about you know
how did you manage your time in uni how
did you find um
kind of the pressure of moving from that
school environment where everything
is almost um kind of forced you
you have to attend lessons whereas in
university you know it is a little bit
more optional how did you find that
switch and were you able to kind of
motivate yourself to actually be
proactive
um whilst you were there so there's just
a few different kind of leading
questions that i think you can ask
people to to get a gauge and i think by
showing how someone approaches an
interview and how much prep they've done
and
if they show up on time and you know
were they aware
of you know exactly who you were and the
company was before the interview that's
all just really good signs of someone
that's you know
organized and has that proactive
approach yeah awesome i like it
so as i said in introduction for the
last two and a half years you've been on
a sort of
um not just a you you haven't just been
focused on yourself but you've had other
people to be responsible for
so we'll definitely dig into that but
how would you describe
your first year in recruitment
a bit of a whirlwind i would say i was
obviously
pretty much fresh out of school i had a
couple of
jobs and you know working in top shop
like the call center job before but i'd
never
really properly been in the working
world in an office
working you know long hours at the start
it was definitely a shock to the system
and you know i would be lying if i said
in that first few months i didn't think
about
just packing it all in and going back to
top shop about 100 times
um but i also found it
very kind of intriguing and inspiring
seeing
these people around me who were
seemingly you know normal people
really down to earth but then you would
see obviously these deals going on the
board everyone would talk about their
commission
and their paper because i didn't know
anyone that had ever worked in
recruitment and i just thought god this
is unbelievable
how did no one ever tell me about this
before you know this is
such an exciting place to work and
there's so much opportunity here so it
was a real eye-opener but it was
it was tough that first year because i
was very nervous when i started and i
was quite naive you know i didn't really
have much of a phone manner or you know
know how to deal with people
just simply not wanting anything to do
with me so there was definitely a few
you know kind of tear-jerking moments on
the phone
he really didn't want to talk to me but
yeah that experience had to come in
quite quickly and i worked with some
really great people at the start of my
recruitment career as well some really
great
mentors within the business so that
helped a lot so
let's talk about very quickly what was
looking back what was your
biggest challenge in that first year
would you say so you mentioned there
we'll see
dealing with difficult conversations
that you probably haven't had to do
before but
if you were to pinpoint it what was the
sort of biggest hurdle or most common
hurdle that you had to overcome that
then maybe helps you progress or
accelerate your career do you think
i think just overall confidence was the
biggest thing for me just building up
the the confidence and being
self-assured in myself to
to say you know i do know what i'm
talking about and this person
should want to talk to me because i can
actually give them a genuine opportunity
here to further
their career and you know i'm not
wasting anyone's time i
i am a useful kind of addition to this
team so it was definitely the confidence
for me
and making sure that i didn't kind of
shy away from asking those difficult
questions and you know asking within the
business
can i take on a bit more responsibility
you know what what's the next step for
me i think at the start it was all
such a whirlwind and every day was so
busy that i never really stopped and
thought
well how do i become like that really
successful person over there you know
that
felt like a million miles away so just
building up that confidence to be
kind of ready to really push forward and
progress in the company
and do you think that confidence comes
from
gabby doing deals or can you
can you cultivate that confidence in in
different areas you think because i'm
sure
that's the confidence you've probably
had to cultivate in your in your guys
right
so do you think that do you think that
just comes from gabby walking up to the
billboard ringing the bell whatever you
do over there
like do you think it just comes from
that or i don't know what do you think
so i had experience quite a slow start
you would say possibly to my recruitment
career
you know i didn't kind of start and get
up and running and on the board within a
matter of months i was
you know a bit of a slower burner and i
did um sit alongside
a couple of people and resource for them
for quite a while before i took that
leap to
to start the testing market and go on
the board as a full consultant so
success for me was initially
number one actually starting to
understand what i was talking about and
get my head around the market
and how um everything kind of slotted
together from a tech point of view and
also it was just feeling
like i was starting to get kind of
welcomed into the community because i've
always done that that same patch that
yorkshire northwest area and
just building meaningful relationships
with people online like i was so
passionate and interested about the
social media side of things and joining
communities and
once that started falling into place and
other people who had maybe been doing
recruitment for three years were asking
my advice on how to engage people on
social media
that gave me you know such a boost okay
how long did it take to do your first
deal then so
if you're a slow starter interested yeah
so i'm
trying to think how long i was there for
i was probably there for
nearly a year before i actually went up
on the board but
once i did it yeah i was i was super
confident at that point and it
snowballed from there so i think
i see people go on the board quicker and
they kind of learn whilst on the board
whereas i felt like i knew the
job inside out went on the board and i
kind of hit the ground running with it
so i think
i think i went on the board and maybe
did my first deal within the first week
and did you have four deals in my first
month and it all continued
from there yeah a slow burner at the
start
i could do it yeah so like why didn't
you quit then because the years
a year's a long time i've had people on
here before that they didn't make a
placement
and you you're not there for the base
salary right and i'm sure everyone and
you
you recognize that from people around
you but why didn't you quit
i think it's because i knew i i knew
that i was doing a good job i wasn't
necessarily
you know a fully fledged consultant at
that point but i was a very very
successful resource there
and you know the company was very happy
with how i was doing
i was getting involved in a lot of
training for the new people joining the
business and around social media so i
felt fulfilled
but it just didn't kind of click for me
that if these people are doing it and
why can't you do it you are just as good
as these people and you know you're
getting irate because you're seeing them
earn double the amount you're earning
but you're the only one in your own way
the company wants to support you you
know you can do it but it was just
me taking that leap of faith sam i would
say i i didn't quit because no one was
holding me back apart from myself you
know
the job and the company was great but it
was just having that
confidence to make that jump to the next
level love that
and then final thing on your first year
then
what what was the the best it's like you
mentioned mentors you mentioned
surrounded by
good people what what was the best piece
of advice you
that you received in that first year do
you think
oh that is a good question
i think one of the things that
searchability is is great for
and i know that a lot of companies might
say that they do this but
they are hyper aware of how important
reputation is and they're hyper aware of
the fact that if you
do it right from day one and you're not
there for the quick win you're there for
the long term goal
then you're going to reap the rewards
down the line so it was always just
making sure that
every every role every kind of nibble of
a role that we got you know we were
giving it our full attention
and working it to the best of our
ability so it was just making sure that
you
viewed every opportunity as a long-term
opportunity you know there's no such
thing really as a quick win
i love that so basically do you so
basically the advice is
or what he was really mindful of was
which is obviously helped is
do not basically just the real
importance of your reputation
in your market yeah yeah okay yeah
awesome so
right so going into your second year
then so this is when obviously things
started snowballing
definitely keen to dig in uh with you on
the
social media and stuff like that on your
journey with that
so just to help me and help people
listen in so context
is so did you then what so obviously you
recruiting the testing market
from what i understand yeah so going
into the second year
was that then where what was you
building that from scratch or was you
then like a 360 consultant so you're
doing clients and delivery
just give me contacts then then we can
dig into sort of your journey and
learning
of course so we originally had
no one focusing on testing within the
business everyone
who did development did development and
testing so i was
ready to take that leap ready to be a
consultant and i'd been kind of teed up
to take on on development in a different
patch
however because i had already invested
this year
into this particular location and market
and i felt i'd really embedded myself
i pulled together a little bit of kind
of a sales pitch
for the directors and said look i know
you want me to do this but i
really really think if you back me and
you let me just do testing in these
locations i will make more than if you
put me on development there
and they they were unsure because you
know there was no
blueprint to go off they'd not kind of
had anyone cover in testing before
and you know i think testing sometimes
wrongly can be perceived as
developments you know a less attractive
younger sister and
it was just not really something they'd
been touched upon but i i knew
that there was a gap in the market i
know you really did know that i would be
able to maximize on that so
so that's how testing came about and how
i kind of moved on to that patch and it
was
pretty much starting from scratch to be
honest so so
keen to dig into this because it's one
of the sort of popular questions i get
gabby from recruiters on
would love you to speak to people on how
they've approached building a desk from
scratch
but i think what will help with that is
tell us what was in that business
plan or like the core sort of
fundamentals of it because i think
that's really interesting right i love
the fact that
you took the initiative to go hey guys i
know you want this for me but
this is why i think i should focus on
this absolutely love that
what what what made up that business
plan that gave you the confidence
obviously
and yeah what did that look like out of
interest
so what i pulled together was the
testing roles that i had
already personally i know hadn't kind of
brought the clients on board but worked
and resourced
when i was working as a resourcer
what those placements equated to
value-wise and then
dug into the clients that we already had
do they recruit and test if so how often
how big is their testing team kind of
market mapping who
we were already working with and then on
top of that
identifying the the key players within
testing recruitment that we didn't
currently work with but who would be
on my hit list if you will so where
you're not what we already have that we
can kind of exploit
and maximize on and where i'd be
targeting moving forward
love that how did you go about it then
how how did you go so obviously so
what's interesting there is you had
clients that you could go after but just
really focus and be like hey
i'm gabby obviously search ability works
of you but i'm i'm the
i'm the testing person i i'm just gonna
focus on that if you have testing
requirements
or testing obviously people that you
need on the person
but so yeah how how did that look then
what was the plan to get in front of
your your target list which no doubt
recruiters will have their own target
list
how did it go how did you approach it
so it was it was as you said there
obviously you know
the key thing is is always making the
introduction and i would say
that i am not a pushy person
my approach i i do take the softer
approach and i
certainly take the approach of um
getting to know people over time before
kind of dropping in can i work with
you straight away so in the early days i
was just having a lot of conversations
with people who i knew in the back of my
mind you know you're someone that could
be really valuable for me as a
connection but
initially just having a chat to them
about what they do explaining that i was
focusing on testing full-time you know
can they talk me through a few things
it'd be important for me to know
so then at the point where the
conversation was warm i i could then
drop in at that point look
you know i'm really serious about this
you've given me a lot of useful advice
who am i best speaking to at your
company to to get a shot at this and and
just really using that network
um so you lent on candidates yeah lent
on candidates a lot i mean i i've never
been afraid to
ring someone and say you know can you
just do me a massive favor
you know i i won't bring your name into
it but who do i know
you've got an email address if you got a
number i promise i won't tell them how i
got
it but people people generally in their
heart
i like to think are good and you know
they want to see people succeed as long
as you
are i would say you don't want to bleed
your network dry
it's it's a two-way street so at the
start i was doing a lot of blogs and
anything i could do to engage with
people to then be able to ask them
you know at a later date the recruitment
question is what i was trying to do
in inventive ways yeah nice so so what
would you say was
the sort of most effective method for
you then in growing your client
network would you say i think
that it was definitely
i i'm not naive to say that it didn't
help that we
already had some good clients on board
that i had worked roles for and
impressed already
and again just had that very open and
honest conversation with them and said i
am starting a new market here
a recommendation from you would be worth
its weight in gold with
other key players in and around the area
is that something you'd be happy to pull
together and i think that's really
strengthened when i was kind of hitting
the phones hard and
you know sending out these introductory
emails just to make it a little bit more
real
and less of a blanket approach when i'm
actually you know connecting it with
real life recommendations and referrals
yeah
so the real quick thing on that so we
all you always hear about referrals
don't you
in training recommendations so like just
just to
sort of finalize that like what would
you say are the benefits of getting
referrals and like
in your opinion what is the best way of
getting them or approaching us you just
mentioned
emails there but like just you're
experiencing that because you hear that
a lot don't you
but like what do you say the main
benefits and also the best way that
you think is to go about get getting
them
yes it's something again the
searchability ethos
is that's always been something that we
have pushed for
and back in the day it used to be all
about the kind of linkedin
recommendations
um right now our kind of big focus is
trustpilot
so that has always been something that's
kind of been hammered home from day one
is you know don't ask don't get no one's
to write you you could be the greatest
recruit in the world no one's going to
off their own back
oh and i'd sit and think i'm going to
write gabby at searchability
you know you need to push for these
things and say i know what i've done for
you so
this this and this and we place this in
this i i can kind of almost pull it
together for you i just need you to give
it the green light and just say you know
i seal this with approvals she she knows
what she's talking about and
i would say you know give her a chance
because she's done a great job of
filling our vacancies so
just being a bit cheeky with that i
think okay nice
so you mentioned and what i was just
then keen to ask you was
you know you're talking about basically
adding value um but at the back of your
head
knowing that that is someone that could
obviously be a great relationship to
form
like recruiters are typically
or can be typically sort of um be known
as impatient
right so that's why sometimes people do
find it hard to think about
marketing themselves or whatever because
they'd rather just call someone and try
and i don't know agree fees or whatever
so how long like so talking about that
period of giving value
obviously you've got the existing
relationships but if we focus on you
expanding
your new clients in that second year
with that approach
how how how long is that timeline do you
think would you say
realistically if you really approach it
with giving value if that's sharing
content
if that's um yeah trying to speak to
people
like how long is that timeline do you
think of getting to know someone
building relationships
to you know what gabby yeah can you help
us would you say
yeah no that's a great question and it's
something that when you grow a team
you have to think about because
obviously you need wins early doors and
you need fees coming in early doors you
can create this brand in the background
but it's got to be combined with just
sheer perseverance knocking on doors and
you know getting
getting relationships in place so
alongside all of that slower burner of
course was all of the usual
you know getting on the phone as much as
possible and dropping through as much
content as possible so i would say
that's probably how i did the first
handful of deals
whilst the kind of softer think skills
was going on in the background and i
would say that probably took at least
at least six months for it to get to the
point where i think you know people
actually are starting to recognize me a
little bit here and you know
understand that i'm kind of this testing
recreation in yorkshire and
i i think it's always a good way to kind
of see how you'll perceive when you
start getting through those emails from
the rival agencies in the area saying oh
you know a client mentioned you the
other day
people taking this particular area by
storm and i think
that's when you know that you know words
getting around and the approach is
working
but it's got to be paired with just the
classic you know
just yeah being proactive yeah yeah
so so just on that then if i'm listening
and i'm going through that process at
the moment
of building out a new market or whatever
like
how how long would you like i guess how
long would you sort of say to them like
really stick it out for this period to
see if you get some sort of traction
like how long did it
take you then would you say was it like
this sort of more six months six months
doing all those things
i would say six months i think the first
six months
for anyone in recruitment are probably
the hardest i mean the first year
is probably you know the hardest it
takes a while for this job to click and
consistency is one of the hardest things
to get in the world of recruitment but i
would say
if you're hitting that six-month mark of
building a new desk and building a
personal brand and you feel like you're
still
getting nowhere i would say that
perhaps something is amiss whether or
not you've maybe not picked the right
market
or whether you think that you're getting
your um presence out in front of the
right people but you're simply just you
know missing them completely
if you're really investing into it and
really um
you know working super hard throughout
that six months
then i would say that that's the point
where you kind of need to take stock and
be seeing a bit of
um kind of result back off your hard
work yeah nice i like that
so how how did you um how did you finish
billing-wise than that yeah focusing out
a
complete desk you know what are you
doing there a great question
i'm trying to think off the top of my
head i think it was
about 190 which i was pretty happy with
for the first full year on the board
yeah yeah nice that's awesome and is it
all perm yeah that you do oh
um yeah so we're not all deaf we've got
completely separate contract team at
search abilities
so yeah all permanent awesome so then
obviously
and then was it another year of building
on what you built before you started
obviously yeah looking at or growing
your team building even more
credibility getting your name in the
market etc yeah
yeah it was that second year again was
just building up further consistency i
think it was must have been you know
towards the back end of that
that we started really thinking about
the fact that there was there was quite
a lot of business coming in and i was
perhaps starting to get spread a little
bit thin and it would make sense to
start growing out this test team now
that was always the long-term vision
that
we you know i want to start the testing
team for it to one day to be as big as
the dev team at search ability and you
know rival that team
love that so you've mentioned branding
quite a few times
yeah let's let's talk about this right
it's definitely become more and more
obviously that that's what
um i've helped recruiters with in the
last sort of year and a half so i'd love
to just
sort of get your take on it and and sort
of i guess it's something now that you
encourage your team to do
and it's clearly something that you've
become known for in such ability
even obviously i saw that you're doing
events talking about it for the testing
market
so how would you define
a pers like building a personal brand as
a recruiter like firstly like what
when we say this phrase personal
branding like what does it mean to you
so a personal brand for me
i would say a personal brand is not just
the roles that you've got on at the
moment or what you're doing any given
month your personal brand
proceeds that so that is just something
that is always kind of ever present in
the background
so despite where everything else is up
to
my personal brand would hopefully you
know always proceed that and that's just
being known as
you know our testing recruiter but also
being known as someone that
you know you can genuinely have a
conversation with and i
am someone that is quite approachable on
social media and i talk a lot about a
lot of things that are completely
unrelated to work and unrelated to
testing
um but i think it's just helps
you to be seen as a person as opposed to
a recruiter or as opposed to
a member of whatever agency you belong
to that's kind of helping you shape out
just your individuality within the
market announce that so like
human first yeah and then a recruiter
right which obviously helps
so okay so like okay there'll probably
be a lot of listening if
if recruiters listen to his podcast they
probably know this is important right
so what i've seen is the number one
challenge as to why people don't start
is like i'll say to you gabby i know
it's important but
what the hell do i talk about yeah what
do i create content about right
so what what's your go to advice
if i'm a recruiter listening or someone
in your team i'm going to be right i
want to i want to build my brand like
you
that are like what are you telling me to
help me start
okay yeah i would say initially
creating content can be daunting if
you're talking about creating
original content i think everyone
automatically thinks
okay so i need to start a podcast or i
need to vlog or i need
to run an event and i think people try
to
run before they can walk so
all you have to do to get started is you
don't even have to create your own
content you can just share
other people's relevant content but add
your take to it
or pose a question so i would say don't
just share an article you know you might
as well do nothing if you're literally
just clicking share from bbc tech news
adding
nothing else to it just actually read
the article
understand it and just pop on your key
takeaway on there or
you know pose a question that's brought
up in the article to get the
conversation going
so if you don't have that confidence yet
or you're unsure what to put out there
that's a great place to start
and i think these recruiters who
want to kind of set up events i keep
going back to the event space because
that seems to be the popular thing to do
at the moment
before even understanding already what
events are out there that are already
being run by you know grassroots people
in the community
why not just get ask them a few
questions ask if you can come along and
ask if you can sponsor it
because i think otherwise it's clear
that you're you're starting this event
because you just want an easy way to
find candidates and it's all about
personal gain
so it's just making sure that you are
adding value and again not just kind of
bleeding that network dry
yeah i love that and and yeah definitely
don't like you don't want to go in blind
if you're trying to facilitate um
events so what what would be then your
number one tip
to stand out in a crowded marketplace
and really set yourself apart
from the competition because this
obviously ties into it but i'd love to
get your take on that because
particularly if you're listening to this
like yourself
you're a recruiter in tech yeah there's
a lot of you
don't know how many i don't know how
many of you there are in yorkshire but
yeah there's a lot there is
a lot of tech recruiters so
but this this is relevant for any any
recruiter any market because there
there's there's thousands of recruiters
right but what what's like
what's your number one tip for
recruiters to stand out what comes up
for you
so i'd say number one tip is depending
on what your niche is and what your
market is
find out where do the people in that
market hang out
what events do they go to what platforms
are they on are they on slack
are they on twitter is there a facebook
group
and and put yourself into that group
hold your hands up and say
look i'm a recruiter but i'm really
genuinely
just here to learn more about my market
because i want to be good at my job and
i don't want to piss people off every
day
woman having no idea what i'm talking
about so i'm gonna you know be
vulnerable and honest and put myself out
there and say i would love your help to
be better at my job
and just find out where are these people
and how do i
put myself in front of them and it comes
back to integrity doesn't it
because if you don't mean that yeah
you'll get found out
simple as that so um what i wanted to
wash it and this is an interesting uh
question that someone sent me which ties
into this so
because you've spoken about events
getting involved with your network and
community
and i think this is might be a bit
specific to tech but i think also in a
lot of other sectors
yeah what do you think is the return
of um return on investment
or spending time really learning the
skills that you recruit for
so i've seen it in a few different
places where tech recruiters now are
going
we code we learn we we've we've learned
how to code which means
we can recruit better yeah i understand
it and i think that's great
but what's your opinion on yeah return
on investment of
time learning that those skills and
really embedding yourself and
understanding what testers do
yeah over getting really good on the
recruitment side
right obviously these go hand in hand
yeah but like what what
what do you think yeah i think it's a
very
fine balance between having enough
knowledge
that you you don't make a fool of
yourself on the phone and people feel
like you you care enough about what they
do in their market
but i also think that it can
be perceived from a lot of these kind of
technical groups i'm in and a lot of the
things that i
kind of appreciate behind the scenes
that a lot of it
is kind of um considered a little bit
infancier when you do see people saying
you know i've learned to code or if in
testing for example i've done my ist
cubing
i quite often say to people on the phone
oh i've literally
never heard of that tool before can you
tell me a bit about it i'd love to know
a little bit of context because it's
something that has never come up i'd
much rather do that than sit there and
try and blag it and pretend
i think i've got good knowledge around
testing you know i've been recruiting
for it for five years but there's still
a lot of stuff that i don't know and
that goes over my head and i'm just
quite honest about it yeah no i really
like that
and i think um what one of the sort of
second biggest challenges that i
get from recruiters tying into sort of
content which is relevant to this is
especially in the sort of technical
world where people would be
uh really concerned or worried about
talking about something quite tech
specific because they're like oh my god
like i don't
know how i'm not as competent as these
people but i think it of course it's
going to help with context and
i guess relating when you're speaking to
people but
you don't get paid to do what they do so
you're never going to be as competent as
them
should you be curious about it should
you learn for sure but that isn't your
job
as a recruiter right what you need to be
an absolute expert in is who's the best
in the market who are the best
employers and what do they offer or why
that person is the best in the market et
cetera do you get what i'm in and that
like that's what you're going to be an
expert in so yeah being honest and going
oh that's interesting tell me about it
um you have every right to um yeah so
that makes sense and you know what the
perfect example is
that the ministry of testing event where
i did my personal brand talk
every other speaker at that event was a
tester and every other talk was
technical
and they never would have invited me to
do a technical testing talk because it
would have been an absolute shambles it
would have been a muslim
no one would have cared so the fact that
i you know say well i don't know
anything
you know about that enough to give a
talk but what i do know about his
personal brand and i know that's useful
across
all industries how about that would it
would it be of interest to have
something a little bit different and you
know it went down really well
so i think recognizing where you add
value yeah exactly and you know post
content
around um interview tips cv
tips you know just talk about what you
know there's enough people out there
pretending to know about things and
talking nonsense
don't add to the noise just stick to
what you know awesome
so quick one on that i reckon there
might be a lot of your competitors going
how did gabby get to do a talk at
that event right so how did you achieve
that i know it wasn't just
from one act or you doing one thing
clearly
this is something that you've been
passionate about and sort of been
involved in doing
from the very beginning of your
recruitment career but
what how do you think you was able so
one clearly what we just discussed
you got invited or you had the
opportunity to because you recognized
where you could potentially add value
to their audience which is obviously a
factor but what else do you think
contribute you to getting that
opportunity
so i think it's all about the chain of
events so if i
really go back and break it down there
was
a testing event in leeds i think two
years ago that
i went along to and sponsored and i met
a lot of kind of prevalent people in the
speaker community
i was then invited to speak at that
event the next year which unfortunately
didn't happen
um but because of that that led to
me being invited to do the the same talk
it's all been the personal brand talk
internally at sage for their internal
testing conference and that was just
you know just something something to do
off my own back and something i was
invited to do
and then once i saw the opportunity to
speak at ministry of tests
and you know this was a serious gig uh
people get paid to do this and i thought
you know there's no way i can do that
but it was actually um john from sage
who said to me
your talk was was really really good
just put yourself forward
everyone knows who you are at ministry
of testing because you're constantly
talking to them
yeah when you're on all their groups and
you talk to all of us
so we'll all back you and that's how it
came about really so just
the long term gain in the background is
to say you've just been involved in
stuff over the years
and again i suppose you could class that
as you know a strong personal
recommendation from someone
in the industry kind of pushing me
forward and it's so nice i've never
worked with him i've never placed him
i've never recruited for sage but
he's just a really nice guy from the
community that i get along with so it's
just one of those genuine connections
yeah i love that that's awesome so let's
talk about
gabby's leadership journey then and
management because that's a whole
different ballgame right
so right so obviously clearly you wanted
to grow this team
back yourself to build up this desk
which you did actually
just quickly actually for contests
because i think that's interesting what
do you remember what you then did you
want remember what you then built
um built on and obviously did 190k in
that first year building that out pretty
much from scratch
what did you then do the next year do
you know
so i think the way i had kind of like a
half year and then a full year
oh yeah i'm trying to remember like the
five years that i've done
so that was the the 190 and then i
think that i broke about 220 and then
last year was that kind of best year
ever and i did
280 last year amazing things are a bit
crazy this year
like maybe not talk about that but yeah
last year was kind of a you know a
really
big personal achievement awesome no i
just i just wanted to highlight that
because i think again more
if more recruiters enter the industry
with that long-term mindset like you
have
you've then like you know i mean that's
that's what you can build on and that's
when you can really start reaping the
rewards of
your hard work so how long have you so
obviously just for context then so you
currently
how big is your team currently so at the
moment it is
myself and two other consultants that
are on the board with the view
we're interviewing at the moment for
someone else to join again in that
resource of capacity with
you to go up to consultants so we're a
fully established team of three
consultants on tests
awesome so let's just
think about it as a as a whole then like
what if you look back like right i'm
sorry i know you're still in it but like
what were the sort of um biggest
challenges for you then when you started
having to be not just responsible for
yourself but responsible for uh
another human being and them doing well
like
what was what was really difficult for
you at first shift
and i don't think you know anyone can
kind of prepare you for
how how different it is from looking
after number one
and to go into growing a team and you
know it is going to have a knock-on
effect
in terms of your results for a little
while it's that kind of short-term pain
for long-term gain you want to build
your team
but in those early days where there's
you know a question a minute it really
takes you away from your goal and your
focus
so i think just learning how to run my
day
and be organized again with another
person alongside me
and i just learning as well to to be a
manager
and and how to kind of have
responsibility for someone else i was
still
you know only in my very early twenties
and
it was quite novel interviewing some of
these people in their mid-thirties and
then probably thinking
this person's gonna manage me i've been
working for ten years and
you know she's practically fresh out of
school so i think just getting into my
head that i am a worthy manager and i
know what i'm doing
and i'm very good at my job so you need
to listen to me and i've got some
some good knowledge for you so just
making that shift um
into a manager is always something that
i think people initially find hard
but you've just got to find your feet
and your confidence with it
awesome so let's talk because i think
that's a real common thing in terms of
maximizing and managing your day where
you're giving yourself enough
space and time to do what you need to to
to achieve what you need to personally
but then also
make sure you've got enough time to
support personal persons
so how because i'm sure this is
something that you've had to get even
better at during covid now
right so what does like how have you got
better at
managing your time do you have sort of
set times where
gaby can be contacted spoken to and do
it like that
or what's the typical structure of sort
of gabby the bidding manager so we tend
to
every week on a monday have a weekly
meeting where we'll run through
kind of what chances have you got on the
go this week where will you be targeting
and just you know a general catch up
as to where everything is up to him uh
and i i tend to kind of expect that
everything kind of gets laid out on the
table at that point you know you're not
then going to be
needing to have a chat half an hour
later about something you know that is
our catch-up to set us in play because
mondays are a really busy day
but i i've always kind of kept the
approach that i want to be
really really approachable i don't want
anyone to ever feel like they can't ask
me a question or that anything's a
stupid question
i'd rather someone ask me you know the
simplest
question then sit there all day
wondering you know
whether they should do something a lot
you know that's not a good use of
anyone's time so
i wouldn't say that i'm ever on kind of
full do not disturb modes
um i think you can always kind of you
know let me know
if you've got a question and it's easier
in the office because it takes one
second you have a quick chat and you get
back to what you're doing
it's harder from home because it's a
team's call or it's a phone call
yeah you got a bucket in your diary
eating today a lot more
so i think i've got plenty of tolerance
for people
asking me a question what i can't really
tolerate is getting the
same question over and over and over
again and that's why i like organized
people because i like it when i show
someone something once they make notes
and then they don't need to ask me again
so i think
it's that balance of being approachable
but don't yeah
yeah too much from that it's just funny
you saying that because uh
i can just relate my so my girlfriend
has a real issue with me because um
she'll show me how to cook something
with the recipe once and then
i don't i don't remember how to do it
the second time i have to ask
and she absolutely hates it so i can
definitely get
where you're getting out of that so
something that i think also is part of
this journey which whenever i've spoken
to people about is like
how have you got better at sort of
getting the best out of your team
because i'm sure that's something that
you really had to
um have in place during this cover
period as well when you're not all
together whatever but
what's been your journey with that like
how have you what have you worked out or
learned along the way that
has helped you get the most out of your
team
so i think it is really truly
understanding
what motivates that individual are they
like i think you know we're all money
motivated if you're in recruitment let's
cut to the chase but
some people are more so money motivated
than others some people really crave
that recognition that if they do
something well you know they want the
praise
others don't care about the praise as
long as they're making the money so it's
finding
what each person really kind of desires
and making sure that my management style
reflects that so if it is the money side
of things you know making a massive deal
of you know where they're up to with
their billings and updating it all the
time and kind of
having that visual whiteboard of where
it's up to or if they are someone that
really
gets a lot back from from having the
praise and recognition just making sure
that you know that their wins are
shouted up and i'm telling my higher ups
and the directors and just making sure
that i'm really complimentary so
just truly understanding what drives
people because it varies
massively depending on who you're
dealing with yeah and this is this has
come up a lot gabby so how have you
have you gone about getting curious
around that and finding that out truly
do you know what i mean because
yeah yeah someone can say to you i might
invited by this but
are they so like do you know what i mean
to like have you have you found that out
day sometimes yeah that's what i mean
it's like yes gabriel motivated by money
i'm i want to buy a house all these
things that's like the go-to isn't it so
it's just like yeah want to buy a house
what how have you sort of got yeah have
you got curious about
really finding out what drives these
people that i know i can sort of push on
or make sure i'm doing that hopefully
can really make sure that they're
performing
yeah i think i'm really really lucky
with my team because
we are so close and you know we are
you know we have that real sense of
identity we're team testing in the
business and we very much stick together
so i you know i speak to them a lot and
i do
get to know a lot of what they are doing
in their personal lives and what is
important to
them beyond just what they think is the
right kind of generic answer
so so that helps massively um and i
think just understanding
them as a person how helps as well to
understanding
are you someone who likes a lot of
clothes management do you want me to
you know sit alongside you and really
work with you closely or do you learn
more by being
set off to do it on your own and then
you know fight or flight
you know if you fail you fail but at
least you gave it a go
so as well as understanding those
motivations it's understanding as well
how people best want to be managed and
how they best want to be trained and i
think
you can only really do that with
spending a decent amount of time with
someone and getting to know them you
know you think you know people in
interview and then they can start and
they can be very
very different you know in good and bad
ways so
you've just got to put a bit of time in
i think in that initial period to make
it work long term
awesome so let's talk about
before we get to sort of the end of this
let's talk about uh
mindset gabby super important always
typically
um is the answer when people say that's
the difference between a great recruiter
and a
top top recruiter no doubt this is
something you've had to really sort of
um
try and maintain um yeah have a strong
resilient mindset during this kobe
period as well i know i i've had
and a lot of people will but sort of
what for you what have you done
obviously over the last five years i'm
sure there's things that you do maybe or
on a weekly basis daily basis or
things that you've learned that really
help you have
the best give you that give you the best
possible chance of having like more
great days
than bad days right because as you all
know this is
formerly called recruitment
rollercoaster that's because there's
just massive highs and massive lows
right oh yeah so what what do you do
what are your like non-negotiables when
it comes to light
right i need i need to do this so then
i'm sort of best equipped so i have the
best chance of
having more good days yeah no
i i love that it was called recruitment
roller coaster because it is so
true and i think sometimes you have to
lean into those so if you
go on a high and things are going well
do not take that for granted
lean into it and appreciate how you know
how well you're working because
it can you know turn so quickly
when things are bad though i think it
took me a while you know it did hit me
hard in the early days i took it
very very personally you know someone
ghosted me or they've
turned up to an interview but over time
i have hardened up against that and i've
stopped beating myself up about it
because ultimately we work with people
and people have their own minds and
you know who knows what's going on
behind the scenes and you can't feel bad
some mistakes or you know some things
that happen are just
way out of your control so just learning
to to breathe and let it go
so you can reset and you know keep going
and i do try and
it is impossible but i do try and have
you know
a bit of down time in the evenings and
and turn that
kind of work phone off it'll go to a gym
class my boyfriend also works in
recruitment
really it's not always easy you know
it's very easy
at work but you've got to you know take
a breather and holidays for me is such a
big thing
which is why this year has been very
very tough
um but yeah just leaning into those
highs and really enjoy it when they last
and you know just trying to grow a thick
skin with those bad times and realize
that
some things are way beyond your control
and you've just got to breathe and let
them go
and what what's what's really helped you
over the last sort of six months or so
obviously i've got the holidays yeah um
to
to get that out of your system like what
what's personally helped you
over the last six or so months i think
that you know sometimes in life
you need things to slow down and i'm
someone that when i'm in the moment and
everything's
moving too fast that i don't really stop
and think about it so
you know i'd be going to three different
meetups a week and i'd be driving to
leeds manchester chester back and it
would be non-stop so it was actually
quite nice to just have some forced time
at home
that was just very much you know a lower
key lifestyle for a little bit and i
think
that that that did help and just having
more time to myself
um but again more time to think about
things and think about the negative
things so just
again just trying to to do a bit of
exercising to keep my mind off it helped
me massively in lockdown
so just just being just being
appreciative of
how often do i get time to yeah relax or
like yeah not not go 110 miles an hour
speed back up again before i even knew
it you know you're back to i know it's
not quite back to normal yet but things
are a lot more busy than they were
ago so before you know it life's back to
the craziness so maybe just enjoy the
down time a little bit i suppose yeah
be present but it's hard but what so
final thing on that then like what
what's been if i said to you like what's
been the sort of best advice that you've
received
that's helped you mentally like you
mentioned around leaning and you've
mentioned about
take a breather but like what what's
what advice have you received along the
way that's really helped you manage
mentally and have more resilience would
you say
just overall in recruitment or in
lockdown specifically
either or just whatever comes up for you
i think i suppose across across both
ways it works but in in the quieter
periods in lockdown what really helped
me was going back to basics and having a
to-do list because there was those you
know quiet times where no one knew quite
what was going to happen with the
industry and just
taking off those small little tasks
throughout the day and you know chipping
away at that bigger end goal
kind of kept me sane if i was only
noting the big wins over those kind of
hard a few weeks then
of course i would have felt like there
was no wins you know so
identifying the small wins always
celebrate the small wins 100
love that so i promise someone that
listens to this podcast that the next
time that sun and i always do this now
this won't be this year
but the next time they said to me the
next time someone says
when someone says back to basics can you
please ask them what that means
because it's like so it's such a common
term isn't it but like and that'll
probably mean that could mean different
things with different people
so you just mentioned a bit there but
like when you say back to basics
what do you mean i suppose just
just back back to basics back to the old
schools it all sounds the same and it's
it's
almost like a wide term isn't it but
you know we're not a massively kpi
driven kind of recruitment agency but i
suppose you know back to those basics
of you know you're only going to get
somewhere if you get that new piece of
business and you send that cv and that
translates into an interview and
sometimes you need to just focus on
those really simple metrics to
actually cut through the noise and
achieve what you want to achieve
we we use the phrase busy idiot a lot so
you know you're super busy and we don't
doubt that you're working really hard
but when you actually delve into what
you're doing
there's no wonder it's not translating
into results sometimes you need to go
back to those basics so i think that's
what it means to me anyway
good answer and i like that i think it's
so in today's day and age it's so easy
for you to call me and go gabby i'm busy
all right yeah what do you mean what do
you mean by busy
i mean so yeah so no i really like that
and i think this sort of
what i take from what you just shared is
when you say that is like also
in that which i think is interesting is
everything that you just mentioned there
is completely in your control
yeah do you know what i mean so it's
like right what can i do it's in my
control that i'm fully capable of that
can help me feel like i'm making
progress building momentum that i know
can hopefully over time build up to
getting back to where i was or whatever
um love that so i had to
ask this question which your colleague
sent me and then i'm going to ask you
five
quick questions okay no don't be
so this question was from kelly harvey
okay and she said well she got two
questions actually i'm going to ask you
the first time
what would what would be the advice
that you would give a younger gabby
so in relation to your career
recruitment would you would you would
you say to her um
like i was saying at the start i would
just say just sound so cheesy but just
believe in yourself
look around and these people are no
better than you
and you know it's i hate to make it
about gender and it's not about gender
but i think because there wasn't really
many women in the business at the time
that were in those kind of strong
leadership roles that it's
it maybe felt less attainable so maybe
don't look for the role model just be
the role model you know you do it and
then everyone else
might follow i love that be the right
model
and then the other question for an
optimist which i think is a really
interesting one
so i guess the context of this is like
what you would do that you think will
give you the best possible chance of
achieving the goals that you want so the
question is if you could commit more
time to one element
of your job that would give you the best
social chance of obviously achieving the
goals you want to
what would it be and she put building
your team building your brand building
your client base
like what do you think i know this is a
combination of things but i think that's
an interesting question
it is an interesting one obviously i'm
inclined to say brand because it's
something that i am passionate about and
i do think it really works
so i would maybe say brand and i think
from building brand i do think client
base will follow i do think that that
goes hand in hand
so you know i wish i had a little bit
more time now
to be as creative as i was in the early
days in terms of creating content
because i think that's something that
i'm probably guilty of
letting for by the wayside a little bit
as more and more stuff has come onto my
plate so just investing back into that
would be great
amazing right so to finish i've got five
sort of quickfire questions don't have
to answer them in the in a quick fashion
just let me know what comes up for you
right so first question
if you could change the industry what
would you improve
i think change from within about the
perception of the industry we're in i
think
you see someone slate recruiters and
instead of people defending them you'll
just see all the other recruiters saying
oh god yeah we are awful but not me
whereas i wish that we would just say
well no actually this is a really good
industry and it's worth
billions of pounds and there's a reason
it's here so a bit more
sense of community which i know you're
not going to get because we're all
technically
rivals but you know defend the industry
don't just say well i'm the exception
yeah you're right they are all awful i'd
like to see a bit more of that
i love that question two
what book have you read that has had the
biggest impact on you
oh see i used to read so much when i was
younger but i've really
lost it recently so or
if you listen listen audible i don't
know what
what have you read or done listened to
something that's had a big impact on you
do you know why this is a totally off
topic and rogue answer because it's not
a book and it's not all
that's okay i actually watched the um
tottenham hotspurs
thing on amazon i love those
documentaries
oh my god i absolutely loved that and i
actually
i really liked um his management style
it was so different to what i thought it
was because i think everyone perceives
him as being you know really hard-faced
but seeing
how soft he actually is behind the
scenes i really like that and it shows
that you can still be
a nice person and be a manager no i love
you mention that i
honestly i i live for behind the scenes
sport documentaries because of the
insight that you get i think it's
amazing
and that's fine i know that question is
very reliant on me people reading
so that's fine right so next question is
if you could write a linkedin post
that could be seen by every single
recruitment consultant across the world
what would you want it to say oh
that is such a good question
i suppose it's quite similar to my first
answer but i would say maybe you know
be proud of the sector that you work in
and do it with integrity
and that you think that you're on a good
path and don't let anyone knock you off
that because
everyone gives this industry so much
stick but you know for me personally
it's given me
such a great life and you know the
ability to buy a house at the age of 24
so you know just be proud of the
industry that you're in and
have your integrity amazing
next question what did you spend
your first biggest commission paid check
on
oh that is such a good question
i had all these visions of all these
great designer bags that i wanted to buy
and then the minute i actually had the
money i thought oh my god i could never
spend that money on a bar
don't you think i did anything that
rogue or interesting i think
most of my money and i think it probably
will have done is gone towards a holiday
i'd much rather spend it on a holiday
than anything too materialistic
yeah what what what was like the budget
holiday then that you spent it on if
you'd be into like the maldives or
something like that
we've been to dubai that was pretty
bougie and we were
on a quite a long holiday to the
philippines as well
that was an amazing experience yeah i've
been some great places
awesome love that final question
what is the ultimate goal for your
recruitment career
oh this is a great question it's
something that i think about
a lot to kind of decide you know it's
hard sometimes in recruitment to plan
ahead and think about the future
but i definitely would say for me the
plan
is definitely to continue growing team
testing
to the point and we're not there yet
where it is the same size and at the
same kind of billing capacity as
team development within search ability
to really kind of prove to everyone that
might have doubted it that
you know testing is just as good as
development
let's go let's go better love that
gabby it's been an absolute pleasure
thank you very much